dans les régions un peu plus éloignées
l'histoire se répète souvent le manque
de relève fait que les champs ne sont
plus cultivées et rapidement la nature
reprend ses droits les terres deviennent
des friches éventuellement des forêts
mais dans l'exemple qui suit des champs
en friche sont remises en culture des
céréales autrefois délaissées poussent à
nouveau et au final c'est tout un
territoire qui reprend vie
[Musique]
Charlevoix
un territoire grandiose célébré par
quantité d'artistes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais ces paysages façonnés par des
générations d'agriculteurs restent
précaires
[Musique]
voilà que de nouveaux artisans
dynamisent l'agriculture de leur région
prend des céréales on fabrique notre
alcool on se trouve à boire une matière
première d'exception qui nous appartient
c'est notre goût à nous autres
ça donne le goût ça donne une fierté
aussi de continuer
la motivation c'est que savoir qu'un
consommateur qui va prendre et dring le
vendredi soir le samedi soir puis ça
parle de mes locaux et puis c'est
transformé à Clermont dans le web
et si la distillerie faisait reculer les
terres en friche quand on veut garder
les terres comme il était dans le temps
Martin Brisson a toujours travaillé la
matière brute de sa région
[Musique]
ce bois-là a une particularité de me
battre avec le contresens du bois depuis
tantôt j'essaie de pas faire un éclipse
devant la caméra
est compliqué
justement il y a une particularité
ce sculpteur est aussi un distillateur
artisan
à sa façon il redonne vie à son
territoire moi une structure
je pense que cette relation là avec la
fabrication de la boisson je pense que à
le suivi solide
séjour de production à la distillerie
meno de Clermont
contrairement à bien des distillateurs
qui achètent leur alcool brut de
l'Ontario ces artisans ont plutôt décidé
de fabriquer leur propre alcool
vodka Jean liqueur leur spiritueux ont
tous en commun un alcool brut fait
uniquement avec du seigle et du blé de
Charlevoix
si j'utilisais du maïs pour faire mon
alcool bah le goût serait un goût de
maïs serait pas un bout de blé de seigle
c'est carrément c'est un choix de goût
donc on a fait pas un choix économique
parce que le maïs lui est beaucoup plus
rentable à la tonne de céréales en
sautant dans l'aventure de la
distillerie Martin Brisson et son groupe
avait un but
miser sur Charlevoix pour fabriquer leur
spiritueux
le concept du grain à la bouteille
allait devenir leur quête
des choses qui viennent pas
c'est l'histoire qu'on veut raconter
avec mano on veut raconter la fierté
d'un territoire on veut que vous
arriviez puis que vous puissiez goûter à
votre monde la folie qu'on ne qu'on a
décidé d'emprunter essaye d'arriver à
dire on est capable de faire aujourd'hui
de retourner l'interse du passé quand il
y avait 117 tirer au Québec puis dire
aujourd'hui on embarque dans mouvance
pour recréer une industrie qui
n'existait plus
[Musique]
pour relever ce défi il fallait d'abord
trouver des terres ou pousse du blé et
du seigle
Martin Brisson a grandi en contemplant
les paysages de l'elocood
il côtoie encore aujourd'hui ses
insulaires
ce que je voulais vraiment retrouver
c'était une histoire puis aussi un
produit un goût moi je mets on s'était
dit ensemble les les associations on
s'est dit si on prend nos trucs à l'île
au coude c'est sûr qu'il va avoir
quelque chose qui va ressortir ça
donnait un enlignement sur quelque chose
qui est typiquement charlevoisier piqué
dans un autre monde aussi
le passé agricole de l'île aux coudre en
faisant une terre parfaite pour les
céréales à l'automne
n'a pas échappé à l'exode de ces
agriculteurs très fluide moi j'ai depuis
92 que je m'occupe une fonction
d'agronome des premières années il y
avait peut-être 8 ou différents
pas de personnes pour les remplacer le
fait de pas avoir de relire puis pas de
capacités financière pour continuer
l'exploitation c'est ça amène à ça la
réalité économique rattrape tout c'est
implacable ça Martin Harvey fait partie
de l'une des deux dernières familles à
faire de l'agriculture sur l'île quand
on lui offre de détourner ses céréales
vers la distillerie il se met à la
recherche de terre à l'abandon
ce champ remise en culture finira dans
les bouteilles de la distillerie
on faisait déjà la semence de céréales
pour la coopérative locale mais c'était
ça donne plus value puis maintenant
c'est se rapprocher du marché du client
ça c'est extrêmement important pour moi
ce sigle d'hiver est le premier à
pousser sur l'île depuis longtemps
il viendra ponctuer le goût de l'alcool
brut
[Musique]
quelque chose de vraiment vraiment très
très émouvant noté pour d'avoir toute
seule
les Harvey exportent aujourd'hui le
quart de leur récolte vers la
distillerie
lentement ils améliorent la qualité des
terres et augmente les surfaces
cultivées le fait que les Harvey soit
capable justement d'aller prendre ces
territoires là écoute c'est c'est moi je
trouve ça complètement trippant alors
c'est vraiment
ça fait que l'empreinte agricole va
rester à l'île aux coudes
mais il y a plus que des céréales dans
la fabrication d'alcool fin
sur les plateaux de saint Irénée Martin
Brisson a aussi recruté un producteur de
petits fruits
et mécanicien il a repris la terre
familiale pour cultiver des camerises
les récoltes sont terminées et tout est
déjà congelé à la distillerie ça donne
le goût ça donne une fierté aussi de
continuer que peut-être que j'avais
arrêté de la cabri tandis que là le
continuer puis on dit
c'est le fun de Philippe c'est le fun de
savoir qu'on a envoyé ça une distillerie
de Charlevoix
Steve vient de défricher cette terre
pour y planter 3000 camerisiers
est un nouveau revenu mais désormais sa
fierté est ailleurs moi j'ai été élevé
sa terre ça fait que sa tête c'est la
fierté c'est de la garder le plus
longtemps possible
peut-être comme lui aurait voulu la
garder c'est propre et cultivé au
complet c'est sûr que moi c'est sûr que
je veux
[Musique]
les alcools
deux jours de temps
deux jours complets dans le jean le jean
de cette série est parfumé avec une
douzaine d'aromates des fruits et des
plantes qui donneront aux spiritueux le
goût recherché
deux jours
et voilà les jeans ont rapidement gagné
en popularité
on estime aujourd'hui que les
distillateurs mettent en marché 200
jeunes au Québec il faut que tu amènes
c'est quoi que tu veux c'est quoi qu'on
veut comme Jean qu'est-ce qui nous
caractérise
l'artisan cherchait un goût précis un
goût qu'il avait en tête depuis ses
toutes premières sorties en forêt
[Musique]
l'odeur de référence moi c'est celle qui
me fait triper depuis toujours là c'est
vraiment quand on vient de pleuvoir on
rentre dans forêt et cette odeur là
cette espèce de complexité d'odeur là de
mousse de beaux miets dire quelque chose
de vrai ça sent pas les mêmes affaires
que la forêt en Europe
pendant une heure il expérimente des
aromates de la forêt boréale c'est
extrêmement compliqué de faire un bon
jean il multiplie les recettes mais sans
succès
je savais plus
pour dénouer l'impasse il fait appel à
un spécialiste des plantes boréales
l'auteur Fabien Girard est d'abord
séduit par le concept du grain à la
bouteille
super
bon Fabien lui présente de nouveau
aromates des plantes et des racines dont
plusieurs pousses dans les forêts de
Charlevoix
[Musique]
des quantités puis aussi des pistes
d'aromatisation il cherchait à fixer les
parfums de son jean qui ferait forestier
puis voulait savoir tu sais c'est quoi
les équivalences à ce qui me parlait
à l'Iris à l'angélique qui met en Europe
à des racines en fait qui m'apportait
qui me disait ça
donc là on a trouvé notre solution
ensemble en tout cas lui a essayé en
fait ces tests de son bord puis on est
arrivé avec quelque chose de fabuleux
des 10 séries est fulgurantes alors
qu'on ne comptait qu'une vingtaine de
distillateurs il y a 10 ans on en
dénombre aujourd'hui plus de 90
répartis aux quatre coins du Québec
c'est distillerie stimulent une
microéconomie agricole
ten ambauche des cueilleurs de salicorne
alors que d'autres mettent en valeur les
champignons forestiers de leur région
je pense que toutes les régions le
richesse particulière sur le bord des
berges du Saint-Laurent c'est un autre
milieu il y a d'autres conditions et
d'autres plantes super intéressantes
donc chaque région peut
amener quelque chose de vraiment
trippant
grâce à la distillerie Martin Brisson
rassemble des producteurs
ensemble il crée de tout nouveaux liens
entre des consommateurs et un territoire
mine de rien de toute petite entreprise
prof façon maintenant les paysages de
leur région l'important alors c'est pas
la grosseur l'important c'est la
dynamique qui a dans chacune de ces de
ces types d'agriculture là
nous si on ne peut être un avenue pour
ce genre de d'entreprise agricoles c'est
merveilleux
[Musique]